in the heart of Iraq's Capital this was
once a rubbish dump
now it's a lush and clean public park
the transformation has been achieved
through a campaign to reforce the city
and expand green spaces
this campaign aims not only at
beautifying the city in increasing green
spaces but also saving such abandoned
lands from public abuse including fly
tipping and illegal Construction
during the past two decades informal
settlements have expanded across large
areas of Greenland in and around Baghdad
unless rainfall has led to Drought
higher temperatures and more frequent
sandstorms
the World Bank says carbon emissions
have doubled in Iraq over the last 10
years a lot of the country's emissions
are attributed to the use of oil and gas
we have about 6 million vehicles in
Baghdad alone if each one consumes 10
liters of gas every day that means six
tons of emissions every day we hope the
Sephora station campaign can alleviate
pollution levels by eliminating carbon
dioxide emissions and providing oxygen
oxygen
municipality workers here say nearly 400
green spaces and Parks have been planted
so far while emissions from transport
sector and power generators are most
felt across the city parks like this one
have become a refuge for many people
especially those living in Islams and
densely populated areas
for residents here a walk in the park at
night offers respite from the dust and
heat of the day
we live in cluster buildings in this
area amid a housing crisis so we look
for a breathing space for us and for our
kids
some people bring their guests and
relatives to hang around with us here
because they don't have that luxury at
home
the newly planted trees and green public
spaces will take time to restore
bardad's natural environment
but for people living here they're
already Reviving some of its lost to
Beauty
al-jazeera
Baghdad